foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
well welcome everybody my name is Janine
I just wanted to tell you that we're
very blessed to see you all here in
worship today and I'd like to extend
that Welcome to our online community if
you're new here you are definitely
welcome here
um I'd like to ask if the kids can sit
up here on the floor on the front
of the stage and if the rest of you
could kind of scoot in towards the
center of the row and make room for
anyone who comes in late
okay we have a couple of announcements
for everybody
so we're going to save the date okay for
July the 3rd that's going to be
fireworks and fun here at Pleasant
Valley
there's going to be free hot dogs and
chips a bounce house for the kids music
dancing trivia plus the city of soxie
did I get that right
sexy
almost I'll keep trying
the city of sexy fireworks from the best
seat in town
okay fun for the entire family so
everyone is welcome
also save the date for our annual
samurama the table Kids Day Camp it'll
be Friday August the 4th through Sunday
August the 6th right here at Pleasant
Valley more details to come on that one
so now if you'll
prepare your hearts for worship
dear Creator God
we prepare our hearts and our minds for
worship
let us learn to love you more
and let us learn of your deliverance
amen
thank you Janine
um if you guys would go ahead and stand
with us we're going to open tonight with
kind of our theme song for the series
most of you have been with us and know
for one it's June so happy pride and for
two
um our series that we've been going
through sticks in six
I can't say it sticks and stones
that was getting scary it was like it
was going to come out way wrong
I was like I'm afraid to try again
because this time might be the really
bad one uh Sticks and Stones as we've
been going through that Series this song
has just been such a fitting and
appropriate message that we believe
um to just kind of be like our prayer
for this community that there would
always be space and room for each one of
us so uh y'all join in as you can and
then we'll keep going with our worship
[Music]
for everyone born
a place at the table
for everyone more
clean water
a shelter in space a safe place
[Music]
of Justice
enjoy
passion and peace
[Music]
for woman and man for woman and man
a place at the table
[Music]
with wisdom and Grace
dividing the powers
[Music]
of Justice
enjoy
compassion and peace
[Music]
justice justice
for gay and for straight
a place at the table
a covenant shared oh welcome me space
rainbow race
of gender and colors
okay and for straight a challenge
[Music]
of Justice
passion and peace
[Music]
Justice and joy Justice
all right thank you kiddos for staying
with us in that first song y'all are
dismissed your classrooms if this is
your first time here our older
elementary school kids will be through
these doors
um to my right and then I believe four
through six is over here on this side
[Music]
you guys
straight out of Psalm 116.
and I love the words of this song
just remembering that the same thing
that has been true for people thousands
of years ago is still true for us today
that he is our deliverer
our maker he is the one who calls us
forward and loves us along the way
[Music]
you have delivered me
I love you Lord
[Music]
I will walk in the land of the living
thank you
[Music]
let's sing that again
for you have delivered me
I love you Lord for you have delivered
my soul from death
[Music]
thank you
I Will Bless You Lord For You Heard My
Cry I reached out my hand and you saved
my life I
I Will Bless You Lord
For Your Grace
[Music]
I love you Lord
for you have delivered me
you have delivered my soul from Death my
fear Thrones
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
we're going to move into the prayers of
the people and for those of you who are
visiting for the first time tonight
we're so glad you're here this is a part
during our service where we want to take
time to lift up the burdens that we
carry into this space and make room for
each other and carry those with each
other
so we're going to read this prayer aloud
together and then we'll leave some space
for each of us if we would like to name
some of the things that you're carrying
in to do that to speak them out loud
whether it's a person that's on your
heart or a situation that you're
carrying name that in this space out
loud together and we will hold that up
in front of God and then we will finish
the prayer together out loud as well
Jesus for this city of Sachse Texas and
for every city and community and all who
live in them we pray to you
for The Good Earth you have given us and
the wisdom and the will to conserve it
we pray to you
for the old and the sick for the Widow
and orphan for the injured and suffering
we pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and destitute for prisoners
and captives and all who remember and
care for them we pray to you for the
vulnerable the marginalized and those
unjustly targeted for their gender
sexuality race or other perceived
difference we pray to you for those
experiencing loss loneliness and
disconnection and for those struggling
with mental and emotional health we pray
to you
Lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us so we lift these names and
situations up to you
foreign
for the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts we pray to you
that they may have life and Light
healing and Hope peace and a deep sense
of your presence
amen
[Music]
there's a Grace when the heart is
undefire
another way when the walls are closing
in
thank you
when I look at the space between where I
used to be and this Reckoning
I know I will never be alone
there was another in the fire
standing next to me there was another in
the waters
holding back the sea should I ever need
him
how I've been set free there is across
the business
[Music]
oh my dad left the dead beneath the
waters
[Music]
it should I Fall In The Space Between
the remains of me and this
either way I'm about to the things
[Music]
to me
is another in the waters
[Music]
me
here is another in the fire one
[Music]
it is
foreign
[Music]
is
standing next to me
[Music]
I'll count the joy come every battle
cause I know that's where you'll be
[Music]
in the Darkness
between us
will be another in the fire
standing next to me
be another in the waters
holding back the Seas
[Music]
I'll count the joy come every battle
cause I know that's where you'll be
foreign
[Music]
just reminded of that scripture that
says where can I go from your presence
[Music]
whether we're at the Mountaintop or in
the lowest Valley he is there with us
he is present in our struggle he is
present in our pain he is present in our
celebration and our joy
he is a God who does not forsake us who
does not turn his back on us who does
not walk away from us but stays strong
and true and steadfast his love is
dependable
[Music]
fullness
continues through every generation
[Music]
come to know that love in a new way
would we feel it connecting with our
very being our very breath our blood
would we sense the spirit of God
[Music]
filling us up
leading us on
leading us forward in love
Grace and forgiveness
in Redemption
in truth
[Music]
God would you come would you settle into
us
[Music]
remind us that we are not alone
thank you for this time together
it's in Jesus name that we pray all
these things
amen
thank you guys y'all can turn to the
people around you make them feel
welcomed and at home and then you can
sit and Brett will bring the message
well
y'all would just keep chatting
that's great Pastor starts getting all
insecure oh gosh maybe they don't want
to hear this yeah no it's beautiful it's
beautiful
um my name is Brett and uh it is so good
to be with you all I want to welcome
each and every one of you and um as
always that includes those joining us on
the line
love you all Lots
um and a shout out to James Townsend who
I mean nearly every single Sunday for
like years has been our kind of I don't
know like online host and James is there
like leaving comments whether there's
like one person on or 10 or more what I
think he James is faithful and uh a huge
thank you James we're so yeah give him
give him a hand
and I also want to extend a welcome to
anyone here who's new uh thank you for
being here I know it can it can just be
a lot walking through those doors they
can it can just be a lot depending on
Church backgrounds especially depending
on history and like I don't know how
things went at the last church and you
know
um it can it can just be a lot so
um thank you so much for for being with
us I want you to know that you are
um welcomed here and and I hope that's
not just words hopefully in the coming
you know the next hour or so and then
beyond that in coming weeks you can like
feel that experience that you know so
it's not just like cheap words you know
we know words can be cheap so we'll do
our best to back it up
um so we are in this is part three in
our series titled Sticks and Stones
um rethinking the church's stance on
sexual orientation and gender and uh
this has been it's been quite the
journey I will say these are tough
messages to write
um you know not every I guess message is
equal and it's probably from a kind of
an internal sense of
um I really want to do it justice I do I
don't like I don't know you know when
you do something every week I get like
not everything can be like hey double
plus you know says a pastor you come to
live with like well this is what it's
going to be um but with these I can't do
that I just can't let it go so it's like
I keep editing you know
um but I so obviously I it's been
um well just from the feedback I've gone
it seems to have connected and resonated
with
um many of you and I'm grateful for that
so the just for those who kind of
haven't been with us the the background
is that of course um
throughout church history
um there's been a lot of passages and a
lot of scriptures that have been used to
um to hurt to tear down to
um even ultimately destroy
um the the lives of people often in the
lgbtq community and so kind of in the
first like week and then even last week
kind of first two weeks we kind of
covered a lot of those passages
um
this message is going to be a little bit
different direction in the sense of it's
um it's maybe it's talking about a topic
that's not touched on a lot in church
but um but I I hope well I think it
should be and
um so I hope we can kind of start doing
a little bit of a Theology of uh gender
here
um at the table and so with that in mind
the title of the message specific to
this week is Jesus and sexual minorities
and I'm using that kind of phrase I know
we don't use that a lot but I think it's
applicable to the kind of biblical text
um so to speak which you'll see as we
get into it and
um so just for a little background
before we read our passage so um the
primary text is from Matthew 19 tonight
verses 11 and 12 but
just the sake of time I didn't want to
read like the 10 verses before it since
we're not really even going into them
but it is maybe a little helpful for
some context in case we jump to verse 11
and you're like where did this come from
um because it is a very unique
interesting passage uh so just for some
context this is
up to this point Jesus has actually been
talking about
um the grounds for divorce
um the little kind of historical context
so at that time uh you know we'll just
say the patriarchy was strong uh in many
ways still is but uh really intrinsic so
like men could divorce their wives for
like any reason whatsoever now Vice
Versa not so true you know so
um so I mean literally it was like
there's even uh Scholars have done some
work on this in like ridiculous things
like the equivalent of of a man
divorcing his wife over burnt toast like
that kind of thing like I didn't like
dinner divorce like it was ridiculous
um
so Jesus is kind of he's tightening the
parameters the boundaries on this and
saying like no gentlemen not so fast and
uh
so he's he's kind of tightening the the
grounds for divorce um and
to that you've always got to love the
disciples in the Bible they're always I
mean they're so honest you know and of
course we read it now we can kind of
chuckle and be like you're so naive but
um they have this adorable little moment
where
um one of them basically chimes in I
think it must be verse 10 because it's
right before the passage we get to and
one of the disciples like well if it's
going to be that difficult to get a
divorce maybe no one should be married
and uh it's just maybe not even worth it
you know it's like okay guys and and so
Jesus this is Jesus response though and
it is it's kind of this cryptic
kind of mysterious
um it's an interesting response so
verse 11 Jesus replied
not everyone can accept this word but
only those to whom it has been given
for they are eunuchs who were born that
way
and there are eunuchs who have been made
eunuchs by others
and there are those who choose to live
like eunuchs for the sake of the Kingdom
of Heaven
the one who can accept this should
accept it
I think you'll agree a little bit of a
kind of cryptic like
uh now I think in the reason I'm kind of
sharing that broader background context
I I think where Jesus is going is
focused on that last part
um those who choose to live like Unix
for the sake of the Kingdom of Heaven I
think what he's saying if you've if
you've read the gospels you know um
there's some irony in that Jesus
actually wasn't like
super like I mean he wasn't opposed at
all to like marriage and family or
things like that he was like that's fine
but he was like really big on the single
life and kind of like hey I mean if you
can stay single you know um actually
Paul the Apostle Paul later I mean a lot
of the New Testament is surprised like
he wouldn't never guess that because of
the way uh many Christians are today
um but uh they were yeah for he was
really big in the single life so I think
what he's naming here is
um kind of emphasizing that that last
category of someone who basically you
know a uniku chooses to live that way
for the sake of the sake of the Kingdom
of Heaven I think he's naming that like
someone who in essence chooses not to
get married and of course back then with
no
um really good ways to like has
contraceptives or anything you know like
it was pretty much to be married was to
decide to have children
um in you know in most cases so I think
that's where Jesus is going is kind of
that emphasis on the last
um
however that's not where I'm going to
focus tonight
um instead what really captured my
attention
um is actually the first part of the
text
um
because I think what we have here is
Jesus talking about
um someone who is a sexual minority
um someone who at least in the ancient
world didn't kind of neatly fit into the
kind of gender
um binaries of like well you got two
options male female and that is all
um and he's he's describing kind of in
his own way of course it's language
today we don't use the language of like
unique and such which we'll get into
kind of the historical context but
um
I think that's it's really interesting
to me that Jesus
um kind of uses this term and then
begins to unpack it now
Maybe
I will say this I don't think this is a
case where we're stretching scripture to
like make it talk about something that's
like relevant or culturally relevant
even though like well that's not really
what Jesus was saying
um I don't think that's the case because
if Jesus only mentioned kind of the
middle and second half of verse 12 where
he says there are eunuchs who have been
made eunuchs by others just to make sure
everyone's on the same page that would
be a castrated male
um so
um there's those who've been made Unix
by others this was a big thing in the
ancient world
um there were certain like even
political positions where you could only
serve in that position if you were a
eunuch
um for example overseen like a king's
Harem that would have been a thing
they're like no no no I'm not just
letting any mail
over the all of my 100 wives or whatever
you know um that was not gonna be a
thing so there were certain kind of
roles
um where those who have been made you
can spot others um and then there's
those he says who choose to live like
you next to the sake of the Kingdom of
Heaven if if he only mentioned those two
maybe if someone could say like I don't
know it's kind of a stretch to say
sexual minority right you know whatever
maybe you're you're pushing this too far
Pastor Brett
um but I think the most interesting
group is the the first one maybe you you
caught it there beginning of verse 12
for there are eunuchs who were born that
way
I think that's a statement
that uh Christians should tune into a
little bit more I think churches should
pay uh more attention to this
um because it's it's so often precisely
churches and Christians who are right
now
the most strident
in terms of having really no room
for someone maybe who's kind of
different
in that way
and yet here we have Jesus acknowledging
like hey not all human bodies
grow and develop in exactly the way that
people sometimes think they should you
know or like well it's it seems like the
most do and so that's the way it should
be and it's like well
sorry uh here Jesus I think is kind of
opening up space for us to like start to
consider like huh maybe maybe there
might actually be more room in the Bible
um for different kinds of people than we
often think and uh so in light of that
kind of background what I want to do is
offer three observations on this passage
number one Jesus speaks very
matter-of-factly here about sexual
minorities notice there's no drama
there's no defensiveness there's no
attack or political grandstanding
um so what is this from what a eunuch
who is born that way what did that maybe
mean like in the ancient world
um there's a Biblical scholar named Dr
Megan defranza and I hope I'm saying her
last name right I'm not totally sure
um but she's done some wonderful
Research into all this so here's um kind
of a passage
um from her book she says this in many
ways the ancient world was much more
rigid in defining and protecting the
borders between men and women than is
the Contemporary West and yet despite
this great fear of gender blending the
Ancients were more open to recognizing
that their binary model of sex
difference needed supplementation in
order to address the full range of human
bodies as they occur in the real world
one such supplement was the concept of
the eunuch much like the term intersex
eunuch was in umbrella concept
a word to cover a range of phenomena
wherein humans did not measure up to the
male ideal this would have been in the
ancient world in their minds they didn't
measure up to like well how things were
supposed to go you know um and so they
were kind of they would make room for
this now what is this this range of
human bodies as they occur in the real
world that defriends the names well as
she pointed out in in the ancient world
they use the term eunuch in broader ways
than we often think of it and I I think
um it's really as she points out it's
the the language of intersex today would
be the the term that we would use and
um this basically you know it's a term
that describes folks who don't easily
fit into the gender binaries
of male female in fact we know um this
is far from like uh you know like one in
a million people um actually roughly
um one to two percent of the population
about one to two out of every hundred
people you walk by on the street are
intersex
um so it's you know it's somewhat rare
but not like vanishingly rare not not at
all and uh it's it's interesting though
like people I think kind of Wonder like
well
you know what does this mean how does
this play out I do not want to like turn
this sermon into a whole biology lesson
and a big lecture you know
um that's not the purpose but I do want
to give a little background so we kind
of can track you know like okay wait
what are we talking about
um so this kind of can play out in
different ways
um an intersex person it often begins at
the chromosomal level so you can have
someone who for example is X Y in terms
of their chromosomes so they would be
like biologically like male but for
various cellular reasons their bodies go
on or the body goes on to develop
externally as female
um it's based on kind of Androgen
sensitivity and such or the reverse
you can have someone who is internally
chromosomes even like gonads and such
like ovaries and have certain parts that
are female but then externally outwardly
they develop completely as male
and um it's interesting actually in
something else difference the points out
is
um
in the ancient world there's because of
the high priority placed on bearing
babies in the ancient world there's
often if you've read scriptures you've
come across stories of like the the
barren woman the woman who couldn't have
children and something interesting that
defranza points out is
um likely at least in some instances
that was precisely because that woman
was intersex right although back in the
ancient world there's no like
chromosomes or I can't there's they
can't study any of that so all they know
is well externally they're female but
they can't have children like why not
um and I think that even and of itself
you know whether it's the term eunuch
barren woman like all of a sudden I
think it opens up in the Bible some
space
right can you kind of take a deep breath
like
ah like there's space
there's right now I just sensed in the
culture where what's our ongoing culture
War for like a good 20 25 years just a
war and everyone's screaming at one
another
and it's very anxious
and I think we often I don't know
Christians get so defensive and uptight
and anxious
and I think what we can do is like take
a deep breath
and just be like hey
there's room for people
there's room for people there's room for
people to be people room for people to
be themselves
um without feeling the need to kind of
box them in because well that's what the
Bible says you know it's like well
actually the Bible and even Christ
himself I think has um makes more room
for folks than uh than we might often
think
um
in fact uh
I think kind of maybe the way I sum it
up is to say and what I want to notice
is how non-anxious Jesus is about this
like isn't that wonderful
I mean because I feel like the more
anxious people get the Dumber things we
say
the the worst decisions we make
you know what I mean because like the
more worked up and anxious and like oh
my gosh or often sometimes it's just
fear of like what we don't understand
you know we just we just get afraid you
know like I don't understand that and so
I'm kind of freaking out and then we
like bring all of our freak out to
people who probably don't need our freak
out can I get an amen like this is
people who need a freak out and so I
think there's like whoa all right deep
breath everyone chill out and this is
what I so appreciate about Jesus is
um like notice he doesn't say for
example and some eunuchs are born that
way and that's what's wrong with our
great nation and you know like no no
none of that um and it's interesting
though he apparently gets zero pushback
from the disciples
right from here they just keep going and
it's like I mean maybe there was but I
he seems to be saying this in a very I
mean as I pointed out it's not even like
the primary purpose of the passage like
okay let me give you a radical teaching
disciples you know I mean the way he's
sharing is kind of like well as you all
know
does that make sense like can you hear
the kind of non-anxiety I mean because
he's he's like making point you know see
over here and we're kind of stuck on
like whoa point a like whoa what what is
okay you know
um I think that's there's something
there for the church
um
not just us at the table but the broader
Church there's a there's a way of being
here that
um I think we need to to learn a
non-anxious presence that man when we
can get in that mode I think that's the
christ-like mode and one phrase I've
been using recently
um with myself not just kind of not so
much in this context or this topic but
like just in life is like Brett don't
get angry Brett don't get don't get
afraid get curious
that's what I've been trying like and
it's hard some of you all know a phrase
like that like it's amazing because like
just the reaction you know I mean we our
mission we just had our welcome to table
class tonight so I've our mission is
fresh on my mind
um and our welcome table is kind of our
like new members or those who are just
interested in the table and maybe
wanting to get more involved and uh our
mission is to shift a generation from
reactionary to Visionary to the person
and work of Jesus
and I think about that shift reactionary
like that's what I'm talking about here
we often people the church is often
getting reactionary afraid freaks out
kind of uh on the fields and like ah and
it's like whoa
relax
um work through some of your feelings
and then be curious and learn
and ask questions
you know like that's I just man like and
I get some of them preaching to the
choir here you know but like I would if
I could be in a different Church a
different setting I'd preach the same
message and I'd say the same thing
you know I mean it would just be like
hey can we like start to see each other
again
yeah
so if Jesus can so calmly address the
fact that everyone or not everyone
easily fits into gender binaries
why can't we
number two second observation Jesus
sorry I have points I don't always have
such rigid points tonight it's points a
three-point sermon this is a classic man
get ready y'all can't wait for that
third point it's probably gonna be
stirring that is how I wrote it okay
um number two Jesus and speaking so
straightforwardly about sexual
minorities opens up space for
transgender and non-binary folks as well
um
and just to kind of get on the same page
again non-binary be those who kind of
don't they don't they don't feel they
fit neatly and you know sort of while
you're offered two options you are male
or female and they're like
you know I probably spent much of their
life trying to be one you know or like
I'll pretend and they've realized like I
don't I just don't quite fit sorry you
know just not and um that's these are
folks who often opt for like they them
you know pronouns
um and uh transgender
uh or trans for sure is someone whose
body right develops
um kind of in one gender Direction but
the the mind
and might even say like the soul is is a
different gender Direction and so this
of course
um leads to what's known as gender
dysphoria distress right because it's
not like usually super subtle
um you know it's sort of like oh wow
this is kind of tearing me apart here
um and it at least what's known as
dysphoria which is like distress a
certain and I've spoken with many um
transgender folks some in this room and
I mean it often leads to a place of um
like suicidal ideation
uh because that that war within I think
again this is where the church like
we have just gotta start getting
non-anxious getting curious asking
questions opening up space for people
having compassion listening caring like
gotta get out of this mode I mean
because even in the lgbtq community like
they're gonna get weird like
you get kind of for your little your
letter of the alphabet you know and then
it's sort of like I don't know about all
those other letters you know what it
like gets weird and
um and and not good so
um yeah with with kind of our
transgender friends right now there's um
well let me give a quick footnote on
this there's currently about 1.6 million
people or so in the United States who
identify as transgender so
not no one you know what I mean like 1.6
million so but in a nation of 300
million right it's still a small
percentage
um and so what's happened right now is
um
and this is true for those 1.6 million
including some folks here at the table
is that basically right now
um politically back to that anxious
thing
that worked up thing that fear thing
um politicians
um they use that
they know that we're quivering nerve
endings us human beings we are we're all
in our Fields you know and
um
I think strategically what they've
realized is um gay marriage is no longer
the the cultural lightning rod it once
could be
to Rally the base
and so they've kind of moved on and now
it's trans folks
and that's the you know there's the
stories and the trying to find I mean
any sort of story anything outlandish
anything you know the most when if you
like I mean
anyways people here like they're just
like people like normal there's like no
one trying to like change your kid you
know like make them into like whoa whoa
whoa you know
just like human beings like wrestling
with their own Journeys and and again
um
oh we need to be a loving non-anxious
presence making room for people and and
so um I just want to name like
to to those of us who aren't trans like
this would be a great time to really
show up for them like love them like
kick them a text like hey thinking about
you supporting you and not only that but
like support them yes emotionally
relationally politically like whatever
you can do to like show you care and
work for change
um I think would be really really
beautiful
um
okay footnote over so so Jesus kind of
in speaking so straightforwardly about
sexual minorities I think what does he
do I think he's opening up space here
for transgender folks for non-binary
folks in other words I don't think our
primary takeaway from this passage
should be like oh okay eunuchs who were
born that way that connects to intersex
therefore the church should be welcoming
of intersex people but exclude all
others relentlessly like no no I don't
think that's the takeaway I I think
um instead what I hope we're catching is
this kind of beautiful
um what we might call a long Arc
um in scripture that's like constantly
pushing and nudging towards inclusion in
fact that brings us right to point
number three in this three-point message
and speaking of Unix born that way Jesus
continues a long Arc of ever greater
inclusion happening in scripture uh of
course it's beyond this but it includes
four sexual minorities
um you and you have to to know where the
ark is coming from you kind of have to
well sort of know its origin and in
books like Deuteronomy Leviticus
you have some we'll just say pretty
restrictive boundaries
um
it's almost like the the writers there
were kind of envisioning that like a
certain type of person you know in
Israelite not a foreigner
um even there were some boundaries
around like gender in terms of male
female like only men could like go
closer into the temple like only priests
could go into like the temple but then
men could go to like the next little
Courtyard and then women in like
Gentiles and others then they could go
to the next layer and then there's like
I'm gonna hit because there's a lot of
exclusion going on and then there's like
a whole other layer of like nope and you
can't even get in here
um and that could be based on you know
religious stuff ethnicity like it could
play down in different ways and so
you'll get that right if you read the
books of Deuteronomy Leviticus you're
kind of like whoa very intense
um and I see where they're coming from
they were trying to do a Holiness thing
that's that was I think the heart behind
it but it it ends up
um being real
um pretty exclusionary
and um so here's like just for example I
could have written many passages but
this is one that focuses on sexual
minorities um Deuteronomy 23 verse 1. no
one who is emasculated or as his male
organ cut off may enter the Assembly of
the Lord
um
so you can see there right where it's
it's like an exclusion thing happening
um where you're not you you can't
worship with others I mean literally
Unix couldn't
couldn't participate in in worship like
I mean imagine how they would know I
don't know okay won't get into such
things but they just they're right
rather to say needless to say there's
boundaries being said and
um
they're being held at arm's length the
gates are being barred against them and
yet even in the scriptures right this is
where people often want to do things
like well as the Bible says
and it's kind of like yes that's the
trick like there's this movement
happening in the Bible so you can go
back and find like oh what about that
you know but there's often something
else the Bible says
you know and it's actually the prophet
Isaiah
who
um
saw it coming we might say long before
even you'll recall like in the book of
Acts there's this story
um where Philip uh the Apostle Philip
baptizes the Ethiopian who
eunuch
right which I don't know again as we
read the Bible with modern 21st century
eyes we're just kind of like Oh weird
story you know or kind of interesting I
don't know why if I didn't even need to
say he's a eunuch I don't know you know
but but if you know the background
you know Deuteronomy 23 1 it's kind of
like oh that's a lot of inclusion
happening there you know but but here's
what's interesting even long before the
book of Acts
well certainly long before the table or
any other affirming Church you know
popped up uh Isaiah he seemed to see
something coming that's what a prophet
is a Seer you know and he he saw it
coming and so I'm going to read this
passage and if you yourself are intersex
transgender non-binary I want you to
just like
receive it for the beautiful word that
it is and if you're not I want you to
just see in your mind's eye someone who
is in that community
and um see them welcomed and included as
I read it so this is Isaiah chapter 56
verses 3 through 5.
let no Foreigner who's bound to the Lord
say
the Lord will surely exclude me from his
people now why would he think such a
thing well because of other passages
there's plenty right
and let no eunuch complain oh I'm only a
dry tree for this is what the Lord says
to the eunuchs who keep my sabbaths who
choose what pleases me and hold fast to
my Covenant
to them I will give within my temple and
its walls can you hear the
within my temple and its walls a
memorial
and a name
better
than sons and daughters
I will give them an everlasting name
that will endure forever
that's God's word for you
because what I just heard the Lord say
even in a culture whether you're talking
about back then or now that largely
excluded and ostracized and judged and
did all the things
um
but I just heard him say is
I see you
I see you I know you
and you are
included
you are included
this is God's heart for people
all people
a few weeks ago we had um
another welcome the table class we've
had a lot of those classes recently
which is great
and um
Amber Butler who's who's new to our
community they're on vacation tonight
they're not here but Amber
um
said she was paraphrasing someone else
but she said you know it seems to me the
church needs to stop
building higher walls
it needs to build a bigger table
can I get an amen
like that's God's heart so let's do it
let's do it
let's stop building higher walls stop
with the judgment and the fear and the
anxiety let's like start listening
talking loving trusting
again
yeah
because that's who God that's who God is
in the name of the Father the Son and
the Holy Spirit
amen
so
as we uh as we come to the table of the
Lord tonight as we take in the body of
Christ and the bread the blood of Christ
and the wine
may as the Apostle Paul would also write
in that long Arc of inclusion
he said um
May there be neither any all these he
names all these binaries he tears down
these walls it's walls of gender
walls of ethnicity
walls of religion
walls of Holiness like the good people
and the bad and he just says like hey we
are all what one in Christ
right that's the good news that's the
good news of the Gospel we're all
included
isn't that beautiful like we're all
included and and so tonight as you come
forward yes there's a place for like
repentance and like you know Lord give
me your sins like that's beautiful and
that can be a part of your communion
experience but also it can be a joyous
thing too you know it can be oh good I'm
included I'm welcomed in and that's kind
of the heart of um tonight that it would
be a joyous reception of of Christ
himself that as we take the one
um
loafer bread the one cup and participate
together so the way we're going to do
this we'll start kind of with the front
rows and we'll just work our way back we
practice what's called an open table
meaning if you're here tonight and you
want to participate then
do it you are free to there's something
in you you're like I don't even know if
I have the right theology if there's
something in you that wants to connect
with the Risen Christ
um then you are you're free to do that
um the red is wine the white is grape
juice
and then finally you can just partake of
it whenever you'd like immediately you
can go back to your seat and partake
there but no one will like lead you
through you know the exact moment of
taking
so this is the table
not of the church
but of the Lord
and it's made ready for those who love
her and for those who want to love him
more
so come
you who have much faith
and you who have little
you who have been here often and you who
have not been here long
you who have tried to follow in you who
have failed
come
come because it's the Lord Jesus himself
who invites you
and it's his will that those who want to
meet him should meet him here
come to the table
thank you
foreign
[Music]
we're going to close with a song that we
haven't done before but
I was recently introduced to it and it
just
caught me in my throat in my heart deep
in my bones just praying that as we sing
this tonight as Jesse sings this that
you guys would feel this like Brett was
saying as as God voice to you as his
words to you because
the Lord knows we have not always done a
good job as as the church
space for people
but I hope we begin to I hope that
that's changing and I hope that it
starts here with us
[Music]
foreign
don't get it
and you can't tell Grandma cause her
heart can't take it and she might not
make it
they said don't dare don't you even go
there cutting off your long hair you do
as you told
till you wake up go put on your makeup
this is just a phase you're gonna
outgrow
there's something wrong with the village
[Music]
they stare in the village in the village
oh
there's nothing wrong with you it's true
it's true there's something wrong with
the village in the village
there's something wrong with the village
feel the rumors follow you from Monday
all the way to Friday dinner
you got one day of shelter then it's
Sunday hell to pay you young Lost Sinner
well I've been there sitting in that
same chair Whispering that same prayer
half a million times it's a lie though
buried in disciples one page of the
Bible isn't worth a life there's
something wrong with the village
oh
[Music]
there's nothing wrong with you it's true
it's true there's something wrong with
the village
there's something wrong with the village
[Music]
oh they stare in the village in the
village
oh there's nothing wrong with you it's
true it's true there's nothing wrong
with the village
there's something wrong with the village
[Music]
if you're new we would love for you to
fill out a little card on the table in
the hallway
that will allow us to follow up with you
to answer any questions that you may
have and to just say thank you for
visiting us
my name is Johnny and if you are in need
of prayer a hug or just general support
come find me after the service I would
love to be there for you
here at the table we are committed to
creating an inclusive
christ-centered community that touches
lives and generosity is a key component
of that mission
so if you're willing to join us in this
we want to invite you to go to
thetabletexas.org
or just place your donations in the box
on the table to support this work
Finance
all right if you would allow me you can
get in a posture of receiving this
blessing
you are a child of God
you
are a child of God
this is true on your best day and it's
true on your worst day
so as you go into the world ahead with
its yet to be determined highs and lows
and everything in between
go filled with the assurance that you
are loved
that you are worthy and you are
respected accepted Just As You Are
and go filled with God's Holy Spirit and
the desire to extend the same Gifts of
Grace and unconditional love to everyone
you come into this week
and we hope to see you back here next
Sunday good night
[Music]